I really wanted to come to Camp Kesem so
I could meet other kids whose parents
have cancer. I just really wanted
to come here and see what it was like to
talk to other kids
whose had experience like me. Everybody
has had a parent with cancer, just kind
of makes me excited because I fit in a
lot more in this camp than other camps
because we all can share something
together, talk about it.
I know what it's
like to grow up with a sick parent or
without a parent because I myself lost
my father to brain cancer when I was six
years old
and it's a really unique experience and
I think that Camp Kesem provides those
children with a community that is really
unique.
I've been amazed by the ability of these
campers to share so openly their
experiences and their ability to connect
with other campers who are 10 years
older than them. It's been all I wanted
and more to see this family develop.
Harvard students are all really involved
and passionate about the activities that
they participate in and I think that's
because the Harvard community is one
that is very involved and active in
giving back to their community and
serving the world. I found that a lot of
the friends that I've made at Harvard
were willing to donate or willing to
dress up in tutus with us and it's been
a great experience for me to see that
happen because we want the word of Camp
Kesem to spread. Camp is awesome. We get
to go swimming, we get to do arts and
crafts, get to do all sorts of things. I
keep having to remind myself I'm a
counselor not a camper. I get sucked into
all of these activities too.
Camp Kesem means magic in Hebrew and I
think that's exactly what we've created
at our Harvard chapter. I think the camp is
pretty awesome. I like this camp I definitely
want to come back next year, it's a very fun camp.
I was only me and that's the way I'll be
yes that's the way I'll be I enjoy being
an oyster.